wakey-wakey everyone is another how do
to stay in what wills it's your dear
friend Applejack with a few brief tips
that will help you get along the most
important one of course is don't forget
to take your joy drink plenty of water
too and a good thing has joined the
water a and it blends your nutritious
school may I be the first to recommend
our local delicacy V Meath of course be
very careful to stay away from down I
just want them to top screaming
fortunately those are these sad lunatics
name in the garden district a no decent
person goes there it's full of dangerous
maniacs who won't take their joy 9 or
may all official signs there for your
safety and protection they friends with
your fellow citizens topped them at the
[ __ ] you Jerry here visit them wait
another friendly guest we will ease do
love our games it's important to stay
young at heart so use our playgrounds
after all if we do whoever will obey
police officers there to protect you
remember they're the only ones who are
supposed to be out of thankful
Wellington Wells is always a deceitful
place if you just do like everyone else
doing and take your joy we'll have a
splendid time and if you don't
one less mouth to feed
I think that's the best one of all very
good